Humanity is facing
a multitude of existential threats,
from climate change to malnutrition
to the rising cost of living.
It feels like we need a hero.
But not all heroes wear capes.
Sometimes they can be found
in the unlikeliest of places,
like on your toast in the morning.
Could the answer to the world's
problems be the humble bean?
Beans are a dietary staple of nearly
every culture across the globe,
and for good reason.
Not to toot their own horn,
but boasting
around 40,000 different varieties,
beans are highly versatile,
nutritious, cheap
and great for the environment.
Part of the legume family,
botanically, beans are a vegetable
and come in many different
shapes and sizes -
from fresh beans and peas to dried
seeds like lentils and chickpeas.
If you're confused
whether you should treat them
as a veg or a protein
on your plate,
the answer is they can be
either or both.
For example,
fresh peas and green beans
are considered starchy vegetables,
while the high protein content
of kidney beans, black beans
and chickpeas
means they tick the boxes
of both food groups.
In a world where
two and a half billion people
are either overweight,
obese or malnourished,
beans are a nutritional all-rounder.
Not only are they an inexpensive
substitute for animal products,
but they're both low-fat
and nutrient-rich,
high in protein, iron,
zinc and fibre.
They contain
indigestible carbohydrates
that feed the bacteria
in the large bowel,
making them great for our guts.
While all beans contain
a mix of essential amino acids,
soybeans have the best ratios
for our health.
Other beans don't have that balance,
but around the world,
people have traditionally
paired them
with foods that make the meal
nutritionally complete.
Think beans on toast, bean burritos,
rice and peas, dhal and chapatis.
Everything is better with beans.
While beans are well known
for their role in - to put it
delicately - releasing gases,
they can also do the opposite.
Beans play a unique and important
role in crucial ecosystems
like forests, grasslands
and wetlands.
The bacteria in their roots
take in nitrogen from the atmosphere
and store it in the soil.
This process,
known as nitrogen fixing,
not only provides nutrients
for trees and other plants
but acts as a natural fertiliser
in agriculture,
greatly reducing the need
for synthetic ones
and lowering chemical pollution.
In a world of ever increasing
temperatures, beans are survivors,
able to grow in a wide range
of climates,
from the broad beans of the UK
to the adzuki of the Himalayas.
They're hardy, on average requiring
less water in their production
than rice, wheat or animal products.
And given that global water demand
is likely to increase
by more than 40% by 2030,
this is quite a superpower.
Beans have sometimes
been misunderstood.
Researchers once worried
that the isoflavones found in soy
could cause health issues
by mimicking the hormone oestrogen.
But, thankfully, more recent studies
have found no evidence of this.
In fact, modern research suggests
that soy could even
lower cancer risk
and help maintain healthy hearts.
Another concern is that growing
soya beans leads to deforestation
in places like the Amazon.
But in fact, nearly 80% of soy
produced in the region
is used to feed
the animals that feed us.
If we ate less meat and more soy,
we would need to use
a lot less land,
which would mean less pressure
to convert forests and
natural habitats for growing food.
Like everything in life,
beans aren't perfect.
For those who haven't had beans
consistently in their diet,
they may need to
introduce them slowly
to get used to their bulk
and high fibre content.
Some people find that conditions
like irritable bowel syndrome
can be exacerbated by some beans,
though soaking and cooking
the beans thoroughly may help.
Kidney and cannellini beans
contain high levels of lectin,
a protein that makes them toxic,
so they definitely need to be cooked
properly to avoid food poisoning
if bought dried or raw.
On balance, though,
whilst beans can't be expected
to fix all the ills of the world,
given their incredible abundance,
nutritional value,
environmental benefits
and the myriad delicious ways
they can be eaten,
the future looks decidedly beany.